ce soir je vais vous parler d'éducation
pourquoi d'éducation parce qu'après
avoir suivi de longues études obtenues
de nombreux diplômes les dernières dates
brevet le baccalauréat j'ai quitté ce
monde prématurément pour véritablement
commencer à m'y intéresser
là comme ça on le prend la main
qui a étudié les matières que je vais
énoncer juste après français maths
histoire-géographie sciences et vie de
la terre physique-chimie langue
étrangère et en bas de la pyramide
le sport et la danse en position
pour certains on a 30 ans voire 40 ans
de différence pour me dire le décalage
qui entre la société et le monde réel il
éducation qui n'est absolument pas
évoluer mais moi ce qui me choque c'est
pas forcément ça et c'est parce que je
vais traiter ce soir parce qu'il me
choque c'est que on met en bas de la
pyramide là la danse et le sport
pourquoi parce que ce sont les trois
notions qui vont être acquises très
rapidement et de manière quasiment
intuitive par les très jeunes enfants je
m'explique un jeune enfant avant même de
commencer à à comprendre ce que c'est
que le monde réel il va apprendre à
marcher donc il va d'abord être à quatre
pattes puis après il va se servir de ses
jambes et puis après logiquement après
avoir commencé à marcher il a couru
donc le sport c'est un acquis on peut si
vous mettez un peu un petit fond de
musique avec votre enfant sait marcher
il va commencer à faire quelques
mouvements à se déclencher donc avancer
donc en deux la danse c'est un autre
hack et en trois là c'est pareil si
votre enfant est assez jeune je dirais
moins de 6 ans si vous lui donnez un
stylo un papier il va commencer à vous
brimer quelque chose et c'est une forme
d'art
donc j'ai commencé à m'intéresser au
monde de l'éducation en le quittant
pour plusieurs raisons et d'abord celle
là et en fait j'ai l'impression que
quelques soucis moi mon éducation elle
peut être défini je regarde ma feuille
un petit peu mais en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'y intéresse tous
c'est un sujet qui passionne c'est un
sujet qui est politique donc on a tous
des amis dessus moi le mien est très
client
mais c'est aussi surtout un sujet qui
nous prépare à expliquer ce que le futur
et ce que nous pardons on ne peut saisir
du futur
aujourd'hui
les nouveaux élèves qui arrivent à
l'école grands la retraite en 2084
quand personne ne sait ce qui va se
passer dans 5 800
on va peut-être assister
à une émergence de l'IA dans nos vies
qui va bouleverser les métiers
on va peut-être dans 10 ans revoir
Michel Drucker à l'écran à tout vraiment
tout va changer
et pourtant je pense que la seule
faculté en tout cas l'une des seules
facultés qui va nous permettre de nous
relever en crise d'apprendre à refaire à
recommencer et le traverser les périodes
qui vont être difficiles parce que
celles qu'on va traverser sont
difficiles parfois facile mais surtout
difficile c'est cette acuité à être
créatif et donc que l'école tu c'est ce
que je pense et ça va être le sujet de
ce talk notre créativité
revenons un peu à l'exemple de l'enfant
que je vous prenais si vous donnez un
stylo un papier à un enfant assez jeune
pareil moins de 6 ans 5 ans dans 5 ans
et que vous lui demandez de dessiner une
voiture sans hésitation de la prendre
son stylo et il va vous décider ce qui
considère comme étant une voiture
organique l'image qui se met de la
voiture
demandez-lui 5 ou 10 ans après de vous
dessiner une voiture si je considère
qu'il n'a pas appris
comment décider une voiture il va
énormément de notaire au niveau de la
dessiner parce qu'il va se dire que
l'image que lui se fait de la voiture
c'est peut-être pas votre image et comme
on lui a appris à l'école à ne pas avoir
d'erreur il ne voudra pas tenter et
justement prendre le risque de faire
cette erreur
donc pour moi plus les mêmes grandit
dans le système scolaire actuel c'était
développe les phobies d'erreurs qui vous
dessert énormément en gros on entretient
un système d'éducation qui vous qui vous
fait comprendre et qui vous apprend que
la pire
des erreurs à commettre c'est de se
tromper
je me rappelle quand j'étais au lycée on
faisait des QCM on avait des exercices
et
qu'on ne savait pas la réponse d'une
question d'un exercice personnellement
ça m'arrive souvent j'étais de ceux qui
essaient quand même d'apporter une
réponse à la question et pour certains
qui restent la tête vous vous souvenez
que souvent on voyait les points
négatifs donc souvent si tant si
l'aventure avec aller je sais pas mais
bon je j'apporte quand même une réponse
ou bien avoir un moins un moins deux
alors que vous l'aviez fait que tenter
de comprendre la question que vous vous
posez et d'essayer d'y apporter une
réponse
je compare toujours par rapport à
l'image de l'artiste vers l'élève
pendant le jeûne qui même si on ne lui a
rien appris à quand même cette dimension
un peu artistique a toujours
créée et en tout cas
sans complexe il a dessus Picasso disait
que tous les enfants naissaient artistes
mais que le plus dur c'était de rester
artiste en grandissant
et moi en fait j'ai pensé assez
naïvement que le système voulait l'un de
type de gens différents donc des
artistes des exécutants enfin plein de
styles de gens différents et en fait je
me suis
résolué à penser que le système
aujourd'hui ne veut pas d'artiste et si
il essaye d'éteindre un peu cette
créativité que vous avez en vous dans
vos 18 premières années en fait il peut
faire de vous des exécutants
[Musique]
là dessus
la France fait une terrible erreur mais
en fait ça n'est pas une erreur parce
que c'est exactement ce que ce qu'elle
veut faire de vous c'est de penser que
ceux qui ont fait les meilleures études
sont les gens les plus intelligents
et sauf que considérant que pour eux les
gens les plus brillants donc ceux qui
sont allés au bout de leurs études sont
les plus bruyants en fait ils auront les
exécutants qui cherchent je trouve qu'il
y a un très bon exemple là dessus que
Charles Gave des bains
sur une situation qu'il a vécu dans son
école de commerce aux États-Unis
son prof est arrivé et a demandé à la
classe qu'il avait devant nous devant
lui pardon pourquoi pensez-vous qu'on
cherche à vous embaucher
à qui on a répété toute leur vie qui
sont les meilleures qui sont les limites
et que s'ils vont des formations les 10
à une autre c'est parce qu'ils sont les
meilleurs
donc on cherche à nous embaucher pour
cette raison
il a en fait le prof a répondu non pas
du tout
on cherche à vous embaucher parce que
vous l'avez fait que suivre les études
que vous en sortirez à 24 25 ans et donc
ça prouve que vous n'avez aucun
caractère
il dit
si vous aviez du caractère ça fait
longtemps que vous aurez monter votre
entreprise
et en fait ça va dans la logique de ce
que je viens de vous dire c'est que on
ne peut pas mentir votre entreprise donc
la masse ce profil dans cette dans ce
chemin de l'exécution et non pas de
formation
prétend comme étant le meilleur pour lui
et donc c'est ce système qui fait que on
crée une grande partie d'exécutant et en
fait c'est pas anodin si notre éducation
chasse du profil la pourquoi parce que
après l'éducation et la phase
du monde professionnel et le monde
professionnel il a tous eu envie que
vous recréer quelque chose derrière que
vous mettez en question s'il propose
comme offre il a envie que vous
exécutiez les modèles que celui qui
était à ma place avant vous exécuter et
que derrière une fois que vous leur
embaucher la personne que vous avez
embauchée donc cherché en lui les mêmes
critères exécute de la même façon ce
qu'il a appris
et
si je suis devant vous ce soir c'est
parce que j'avais au début moi j'ai
commencé très très tôt mais j'avais au
début ce sentiment et cette naïveté de
penser qu'on pouvait changer
ça très tôt certaines pandastrisme
malgré ce que je dis en me disant en
fait
tous les animaux passés tous les époques
vont être dur on va avoir besoin de gens
créatifs de gens qui vont être capables
d'entreprendre de sortir de situations
difficiles et donc je m'étais dit mais
c'est assez bête il faut apprendre très
tôt aux élèves au Lyciens au collégiens
et demain aux étudiants puis il y a deux
voies en fait possible une fois qu'on
sort du lycée c'est d'avoir un peu
classique qui est la bonne universitaire
dans un philosopher continue à se former
et c'est la voie peut-être de
l'entrepreneuriat
ou l'avoir artistique pour ceux qui sont
un peu plus créatifs que nous qui va
vous permettre d'abord de d'insuffler
certaines idées votre création et le
faire ce que vous avez envie de faire
mais en fait encore une fois c'est à
chaque fois je regarde là dessus ça le
système de l'autre
et si vous le croyez pas je vais vous
donner un chiffre qui est très clair et
assez tôt
si le système voulait que tout le monde
s'épanouisse dans ce qu'il fait
vous n'aurez pas je trouve c'est grave
comme on dit aujourd'hui
1% de la population française se
partagent 60% des richesses captées
qui à la richesse gouvernement la
richesse s'implique l'influence implique
le pouvoir donc c'est une forme
de liberté c'est un peu le sujet
et en fait dernièrement j'entendais un
penseur qui disait
le monde sera fracturé entre deux genres
de population le jour où il y a la
véritablement la règle dans nos vies
parce qu'elle a vraiment bouleversé pour
le coup déjà nos métiers c'est-à-dire
que la moitié des métiers qui disent
aujourd'hui vont forcément mourir
et ceux qui sont capables de se relever
ce sont les tempéraments les plus
créatifs à qui on aura appris que
lorsqu'on a pas la réponse on la trouve
en faisant quelque chose on la trouve
entre le vent on la trouve en recréant
et dit qu'en fait malheureusement comme
on n'a pas travaillé les gens avoir ce
tempérament créatif et savoir se relever
recommencer refaire on a aujourd'hui ce
chiffre là d'important et on a
aujourd'hui un espèce d'apartheid entre
ce qu'il appelle les gens intelligents
dans la bouquin la carte des
intelligence de la référence et les gens
moins doués moi j'ai même plus loin j'ai
la même jusqu'à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a
une fracture extrêmement forte
et c'est ce que décrit Harari dans son
bouquin en modélisme entre pareil deux
types de population de genre de
population
les dieux c'est ce qui décrit comme
étant les dieux et les gens
[Musique]
je ne me résous pas à me dire que il y a
deux gens de population et que ça ne
changera pas on peut pas le changer par
l'éducation on l'a compris le système de
le veut pas
parler d'éducation dans la formation
alors là ça serait 9 parce que je vous
dise mon ouverture c'est comment on fait
j'ai pas la réponse non plus mais on
essaye d'apporter une réponse lorsqu'on
aborda un sujet comme celui-ci alors
nous on a essayé de l'aborder ce sujet
mais on pense qu'on peut aller à la
source et apprendre aux élèves à rester
entre eux à communiquer entre eux à
s'entraîner et à ne pas croire que il a
qu'un chemin à ne pas croire qu'il y a
aucune réponse à la solution
qu'on vous propose à la question pardon
qu'on
vous donne entre les mains et à faire
que demain l'entraide parce que nous
c'est ce qu'on fait sur notre
application et on a énormément de gens
et ça m'a
c'est en train de créer un mouvement
demain permettra à chacun de réussir et
et
aux collectif
voilà merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]